I take stories because I want to be I
want to look the bit I don't ever want
to feel like I'm second-best I want to
look the best and in terms of widespread
it's all over or every single Jim has it
a lot of people get like acne inside of
that I'm not really an acne prone person
I've had a bit of guy know but which is
where you have inflammation is like the
nipple which isn't really that big of a
deal to be honest view her I just got
rid of that with some tablets I mean the
the health issue for me right now it's
not really I feel I feel healthy I feel
on top of the world
so when I take steroids I feel a lot
better than when I'm off obviously I
live living and I want a care about him
I don't really want him to do it but it
is a big part of his life you just look
in the mirror like a lot of times a day
and it really does mean a lot to him my
looks line so I mean he just if he's
happy doing it then I'm happy for him
but I mean he knows the rest and he just
wants to be big and mostly I guess